you know you can you can feel connected
to your friends and you can feel
connected to colleagues and you can feel
connected to family but but these people
aren't cuddling with you in bed Ernest
Becker in his book the denial of death
says that love is a cosmology of two so
it's this idea that you create a shared
interest subjective life world together
you know like and this idea of like
creating a world together I mean it's
like that phrase inside baseball there's
a camaraderie that comes from having our
own language our own inside jokes our
own baby talk our own set of shared
references and set of shared experiences
and so you know it might start with just
a spark where you feel intuitively
but this person kind of gets me you know
the glimmer in their eye the way they
look back at me when I say something it
just feels like they're understanding me
in a very deep level almost beyond words
there's the nonverbal tuning in their
attuned to me and that's reassuring
you immediately feel kind of like they
get you and then you're kind of getting
them and then that starts to create the
the kind of irresistible kind of
butterflies in the stomach where you're
kind of smiling at each other a lot
because there's there's a giddiness that
emerges a childlike getting us from from
feeling seed and then it opens up a set
of possibilities about how much deeper
this can go
and so then comes the desire to want to
take intentional authoring of this
growing connection okay let's take a
trip together let's go somewhere that
none of us have ever been you know this
alien let's go orbit around some alien
landscape which will just push us closer
together
and create a shared experience narrative
that again starts to cement this idea of
our world then let's find music that we
both love let's find our song or let's
find a playlist it's like our playlist
oh we went to Tokyo together and we got
stung and we listened to the Beatles and
saying let it be and it's like that then
becomes like our shared world and it's
just for us and so the more you start to
feel connected the more you to feel like
you're not alone which you know you can
you can feel connected to your friends
and you can feel connected to colleagues
and you can feel connected to family but
but these people aren't cuddling with
you in bed so it's like when you're
connected to somebody and you're sharing
some of the most intimate in between and
not just when you're like dressed and
you already brushed your teeth and
you're already out of the world but like
you're like emerging into consciousness
in bed together you're taking baths
together I mean there's there's just
this candid candor unguarded nakedness
that continues to cement the feeling of
the connection and yeah it's it's it's a
yummy thing I kind of live for the
experience if anything my
my problem comes from loving feeling
connected so much that then they're
sometimes emerged thoughts of fear
around losing that connection I don't
want you to go away they don't want you
to ever die I don't want the ravages of
time or entropy to rob me of how safe I
feel around you the world is the world
has been brought down to science because
of me I can handle a world that is
normally overwhelming because you're
there you know I can take more risks
because you're there but if you're not
there what you know what will I do
there's a fear around that as well it's
so and so because of the ephemerality of
life the transitory nature the fleeting
nature of our lives
even our greatest ecstasy's of trust in
connection are often tinged by some at
least for me but again my response to
that has not been succumb to despair but
to double down on a agents buck I'm
gonna love you anyway I'm gonna try
anyway like we're gonna imprint
ourselves emotionally on each other
we're gonna create our playlists we're
gonna like take MDMA together and like
really experience the the world of being
gods outside of time
[Music]